Okay, now that we have some tools,
we can dive into basic algorithms.
Let's say you have an array
sorted in numerical order and
you want to see if a number that
you have exists in this array.
If you start at the front and
check every number in the array,
the time could be O(n) if
your number is really big.
The same happens if you
start at the other end.
You could have a really small number and
it might end up taking
linear time in worst case.
However, we could do a cool trick
here that takes advantage of the fact
that you have a sorted array.
Rather than starting at the end,
let's say you started in
the middle of the array.
You could say, is my number bigger or
smaller than the one in the middle.
Since my number is bigger,
I know that it'll have to be in
the second half of the array.
Now I don't even have to search
the first half of the array.
The best thing about this strategy is
that you can make the same assumption
again, just on the second
half of the array.
Check the middle element and
then move forward from there.
My number is still bigger than
the middle of this array, so
now I only have to
check the last element.
And now we're at the end.
We've checked 19 and 29, two numbers
side by side, and we still don't see 25.
Thus, we can conclude 25
does not exist in our array.
Guess what?
You just learned an algorithm.
An algorithm is really just a high
level description of a trick for
solving a problem.
This one happens to be
called binary search.